salut la team mantallot j'adore à
arriver en sautant aujourd'hui je vous
donne une méthode pour trouver à quoi
pense une personne cette technique de
mentalisme on ressemble un petit peu au
cul berlin 10 mais attention c'est pas
du cube arrondissement que ce soit bien
clair
mais c'est vrai que ça y ressemble quand
même concrètement on va choisir d'un
stock d'information une manière de faire
une dichotomie ou en tout cas de
séquencer l'information pour avoir des
réponses du type oui ou non et pour
accéder aux pensées de la personne vous
allez simplement lui tenir les mains
juste lui tenir les deux mains dans
cette vidéo je vous donne tout la
méthode pour faire ça je vous ai fait
aussi une vidéo de démonstration en tout
cas je vais la faire parce que j'ai rien
qui passe à la maison tout à l'heure on
va filmer la démo que je vais mettre ici
je ne sais pas encore à quoi ça
ressemble puisque je n'ai pas encore
fait et ça me permettra d'être un petit
peu plus concis dans les explications et
vous pourrez cliquer là c'est une vidéo
non répertoriés qui se trouve également
dans le descriptif mais il a pensé à
tout et ben oui on essaie vous prenez
les deux mains de la personne en face de
vous une distance normal vous pouvez
êtes assis ou debout ça n'a aucune
espèce d'importance et donc voulu tenez
les mains comme ça je prends l'exemple
du jeu de cartes parce que tout à
l'heure je le faire avec un jeu de
cartes comme ça on aura 50 de
possibilité
ça pourrait être n'importe quelle liste
ou vous pouvez séquences et n'importe
quel mot qui fait partie d'un ensemble
après forcément ça augmente le processus
bon pour 52 cartes vous prenez les deux
mains de la personne et vous lui
demandez de différencier c'est demain
l'une des mains sur la wii l'autre des
mains sur un non ça c'est l'étape la
plus importante
elle est essentielle si par exemple la
personne à une montre je demande de
focaliser sur la montre et je lui dis
que cette montre là ce sera le nom ou le
wood d'ailleurs peu importe mais il faut
que ce soit très clair pour la personne
de savoir à quel mal dit oui et à kehl
maadi non si un joli bijou surnomme vous
pouvez dire alors cette manne à ce sera
le oui souviens toi le bijou c'est beau
c'est oui je reprends les demain que
j'ai fait tomber balsan lisible mais
c'est pas grave
et vous lui demandez juste de ce que
concentré de vous répondre uniquement
par oui ou par non tout le temps mais
quand la réponse est oui de concentrer
toute son énergie mentale
oui l'énergie mentale ça veut rien dire
on est bien d'accord mais n'empêche
qu'en dix ans ce mot là le processus
fonctionne mieux
en fait la personne doit diriger
l'ensemble de ses pensées et se
focaliser sur la main oui si elle pense
oui et sur la main non si elle pense non
et vous allez bouger les deux mains
comme ça sans poser de questions au
départ évidemment donc les deux mains
sont relativement molle et save a
habitué le mouvement et vous commencez à
parler à la personne en lui posant des
questions simples
des questions dont vous connaissez la
je m'appelle fabien c'est pas vraiment
une question d'ailleurs vous fait des
affirmations et elle a dit oui ou non
dans sa tête
donc je m'appelle fabien je m'appelle
fabien on est chez moi en ce moment on
est chez moi en ce moment j'ai un
t-shirt avec un escargot géant t-shirt
avec un escargot ça va vous permettre de
commencer à ressentir un petit peu comme
dans le cul berland 10 mhz c'est pas
forcément un calibrage
mais ça vous permet de ressentir un
petit peu les réactions parce que c'est
très simple à chaque fois que la
personne va se focaliser sur la main
alors dans ce cas là elle va oublier
l'autre main donc la main négative
dirons-nous va devenir un petit peu
molle alors que la main pour auzits yves
la main où la personne est concentrée à
voir un petit peu plus de résistance et
c'est là où tout est le secret donc pour
reprendre l'exemple du jeu de cartes
pour les familles vous faites c'est du
pic c'est du pic c'est du pic c'est du
coeur c'est du coeur ces écarts au sein
du carrosse il tresse et du trech de
temps en temps vous pouvez aussi feinter
pour revenir sur des questions plus
basique un petit peu comme celle de
calibrage au départ parce que ça remet
un petit peu les choses en place mais
pour tout ça via la démo cayla
l'important c'est que vous ayez compris
le principe est que vous puissiez essayé
alors forcément c'est un petit peu comme
pour tout il faut répéter un petit peu
quoi il faut s'entraîner il faut oser
raté pour après mieux réussir et après
avoir un acquis et savoir le faire
surtout quand vous voulez si vous avez
une question là dessus c'est dans les
commentaires que ça se passe vous pouvez
vous répondent entre vous et puis moi
aussi je poste mère je lis toujours tous
les commentaires je sais qu'on
s'approche très dangereusement des
100000 au moment où je fais cette vidéo
là où je suis en train d'enregistrer et
je n'ai pas oublié ce que j'ai dit dans
la première foire aux questions de la
chaîne à l'époque où on n'était que 700
et j'ai pris un engagement devant vous
que je respecterai je suis déjà en train
de réfléchir à comment ça va se faire et
je ne prendrai plus d'engagements à la
légère voilà j'espère vraiment que cette
vidéo vous aura plu vous pouvez laisser
un pouce en l'air parce que ça c'est
cool vous pouvez également vous abonner
à la chaîne puisque comme même le mental
blog il faut le dire cette vidéo par
jour pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier
jusqu'au 31 décembre rendez vous demain
à 17 heures ciao
je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23
septembre à la garenne colombes c'est la
date la plus proche de paris si jamais
vous voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site